[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa vie est simple il n'est pas à
plaindre en cours il a de bonnes notes
qu'il a des potes extravertie il sort il
est plein de vie et vous vous l'avais
déjà remarqué à cause de ces geste
efféminé un bouc émissaire parfait que
vous pouvez humilié sans la moindre
difficulté
c'est un garçon donc qu'ils aient joué
par lui et a donc toute sa vie et bien
en fait et d'un coup il trouve un
dossier sur lui où il embrasse louis
donc ça montre qu'il est homosexuel et
petit à petit se fait harceler de plus
en plus et au final il finit par se
suicider parce qu'il en a marre de tout
ça sous ses yeux les commentaires
moqueurs défilent les insultes à ton
sans aucun répit
seul homosexuel tonnes aider à
dégoûtant pédales
sage est content vous êtes les auteurs
de ces pauses juste un divertissement
pour vous sentir intéressant le collège
la pointe des châteaux passionnant mais
il ya des gens il ya des élèves qui sont
harcelés tout ça et ben voilà tous les
sujets du bassin nominal corps vous les
appelez mais défend on vous rendez
parlera de la gravité voulu plier sa
dignité
c'est de pire en pire ils n'osent plus
sortir ne sais pas comment réagir
lui souffre le martyre ya beaucoup trop
de gens qui meurent à cause de ça et on
a voulu un peu sensibilisé les gens par
rapport à ce sujet mais vous écoutera
projet vous l'avez tué sans même
vérifier vous avez dans votre agissez
dès maintenant
stoppez vos messages violents qui
pourraient tuer un autre adolescent on
est riche de différences ne laisser
personne dans l'ignorance
il est innocent juste un simple
adolescent victime d'harcèlement
car à vos yeux différents il est
innocent juste un simple de lait sans
victime d'un saignement finalement pas
si différent